hello everyone here i thought uh my time
uh with recording in the 1b3 course
is over but it was not meant to be and
uh
here i am back with two epic miniatures
which happened
after the release of my course or almost
i think the timeline is i think just two
days before the
course was released that was an epic
miniature then there was one more
miniature which was
after the course was released so let's
have a look at
those two amazing miniatures so
of course the movies b3 um after a
successful outing in the indian
qualifiers
where i used the larson to a devastating
extent
and this was the key for me uh to
qualify
to the melt waters championship store
where i'll be
uh playing against the likes of magnus
khalsa and anishkiri rajabo
levon aronian karyakin fabiana corona
everyone
so uh i was joking that i might get to
play
1v3 against magnus carlsen or anishikiri
but before that i got the chance to play
1v3 against david navarra in the mr doji
invitational
so let's have a look at what happened in
that game
and you by now you must have really
heard of this game otherwise let's have
a
look and have some fun and learn a lot
of concepts in the same
in all in one guys all in one in this
game
so bishop to b2 knight uh c6
c4 of course we are just getting the d5
square
uh this is the main concept that this is
what this is the basis of our
course after night of six year night of
three i do recommend e3 in the main
course but this is definitely a very
interesting sideline and
it might work very well in blitz and
rapid formats
so the point is after an id e4 we go
knight d4
and uh black has to more or less go for
bishop d5
and he has to enter this line with
knight f5 uh
there are many mores but in this game
let's have a look at uh
short casual and uh
yeah here i played e3 here i was really
hoping that uh he would go rookie eight
uh which was all what wesley played
against nepo where i intended to
unleash the uh spectacular novelty with
knight d sound
kingdom going to h5 with a very crushing
attack
uh but you know he it was
like something else which happened in
the game uh
david went for d5 and after seek takes
d5 i think it was
like more or less like a instinct he
could not uh he could not believe that
i'm doing
some nonsense with bishop b2 on knight
f5 and he went for the most natural
knight takes d5
but before that i should also mention
that the right move in this position is
knight b4
this is the most sound to neutralize
white's initiative and this is what
david played uh samos some like two
games later
like in the next black game in the match
this is what he played and he got a good
position
but i have covered this in more depth in
the uh netpo was a shiro
in the notes to the nepo as a shiro
model gear in the model games chapter
so i have a cdx d5 he went for knight x
d5 and i was so excited i was like okay
yes
now i'm gonna win the g7 pawn and i was
about
to take on g7 with the knight when i
suddenly noticed
what if i don't what if i just go for
queen to g4
and suddenly as you can see like i could
not believe that
it's like almost a force mate there was
just nothing he could do
for instance if he goes for something
like g6 he just finished the game with
knight at six and the power of the
bishop is
clearly seen in this line and if he goes
knight of six to stop uh
yeah okay you cannot stop queen jason
that's the whole point so i mean just
amazing yeah like in just nine moves i
bet uh super gm
uh on a world-class player like david
navarra with our very own
b3 and uh i guess uh there are still a
lot of
uh traps and pitfalls to be avoided in
the names of arson so
i think you should just get on the
cowboy train and also become
part of the revolution i created
which we'll be seeing in the very next
game